I want to count you down the open with
the top headlines hitting our radar
before the bell joining me today is
bloomberg's Bob every and also Olivia
stern okay guys let's start right now
with Apple which we just heard is now
going to be joining a Dow the stakes are
high for the new Apple watch which
debuts on Monday developers from
companies like Facebook Vmw are locked
away it's so interesting it's secret lab
yeah busy testing the apps for the watch
the lab is located the Apple
headquarters in Cupertino California
it's tightly controlled you can this
isn't Apple the best at marketing and am
i creating the drama this secret lab how
did we find out about the secret lab oh
let's see Apple probably told us about
it 30 million of these watches are
supposed to be sold in the first year so
take a lesson from this terrific
marketing campaign I suppose but it is
the first new product launched you're
gonna get one you're with Bob I'm with
Bob all right on this it's the first new
product launch for Apple since 2010 you
say they're gonna sell 30 million over
the course of the next year by her
couldn't get anywhere near the iphone 75
million iPhones are sold in the fourth
quarter of last year it doesn't have to
think about great marketing every time
there's a new iphone that's rolled out
somebody loses it in a bar sometimes yes
can we talk about it no but you're right
they've turned these product launches
into concert events it's right yeah yeah
okay speaking of Apple number stud no
number seven new reports this morning a
fraud involving Apple pay criminals have
been typing stolen credit card numbers
into the mobile payment system and then
trying to make their purchases that's
prompting banks to now require users to
call them before they activate credit
card accounts to use Apple pay okay a
couple of things first of all I have to
admit I am a big fan of Apple pay i use
it almost every single day in yellow cab
first i would like to point out that
eighty percent of the unauthorized
purchases have been for big-ticket items
bought with smartphones at apple's own
stores so they're buying expensive
hardware devices because there's that
you know great resale value it's not the
stuff they're buying from whole foods or
for walgreens so they're buying it at
the apples the other very important
point is that the technology is not the
problem the problem is with the
authorization process with the credit
card companies and the way a lot of
people are getting around it is
demanding that you call your bank which
I had to do with Wells Fargo to get my
visa on my Apple pay she's saying that
the technology the advances haven't
really caught up to what Apple pay the
problem is they're they're entrenching
visa and all the credit card companies
they're still going to them and that's
where the issue is is authorizing the
credit card users account with the phone
is not the actual Bluetooth technology
that is still secure well you know Apple
has been famous for never for no viruses
on their systems right so here's a [ __ ]
in the armor it is ok number six guys
could the use of self-driving cars save
lives according to a mckinsey report the
widespread use of self-driving cars
can't believe this guy's could reduce
accident by ninety percent and prevent
and this would be wonderful prevent
thousands of deaths plus it could save
190 billion dollars in damages and
health care costs I know that driverless
cars will likely reduce traffic but
accidents I don't know I don't know I
make sense and also maybe the technology
will be there but at the pace at which
regulators currently move and Congress
does you actually think this is gonna be
legal I mean I think this is one of
those cases where the fork yeah I like
the whole drive this car yeah i think i
think the driverless car ecosystem that
we're getting way too far carried away
with this story i mean that there's an
example in the article about how back in
two thousand we were saying we were
gonna have hydrogen fuel cell powered
vehicles by 2020 that's not gonna happen
we may still have those cars but but
just not just not so quick all right
well i'm the only one here who remembers
the world's favor the 1930s right they
said 1965 you look so good yeah for 103
by 1965 we're gonna have travel around
in jet packs and monorail who's gonna
we're gonna go from city to city listen
i love the idea we do but you said yet
you use yellow cabs not jet how did you
know i remember i used to watch back to
the future and ask my dad when we were
gonna have flying cars yes when so maybe
driverless flying cars I don't know I
thought that makes more sense I think
we're gonna have driverless I do okay
okay look you know I'm gonna be my
lifetime but